i'm never gonna forget this interview
bro
that's good this is like crazy um
wow okay [ __ ]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today i'm joined
by young sinatra himself you know him as
logic
he's released three studio albums
including the critically acclaimed
everybody which shot to the top of the
billboard albums chart earlier this year
and he's a man that beat uncharted 4 in
one day but how will he fare against the
wings of death
we'll find out today logic welcome to
the show yeah that was like the most
coolest intro i've ever been given thank
you um for those of you who are watching
i'm extremely
[ __ ] nervous can i curse go ahead man
[ __ ] i'm so i'm so nervous right now
how are you with hot food i'm terrible
you think i'd be good because when i was
20 years old i lived
in my homies basement his name is big
limbo and he's indian and
if there's anything you should know
about beautiful brown people is they
like their food very spicy
so we ate a lot of like curry but i
couldn't handle it so this is probably
the first spicy thing i've eaten since
then
[Music]
so this first one is crystal and even
for a guy without much of a spice
foundation i think you'll be good on
this
all right here we go let's do it
[Music]
okay all right so i think that it's
natural to kick things off
in your pre-wrap days when you're
working in the kitchen making drums and
flats at wing stop
bro yes how do you know about that
did you take your wing making seriously
or was it just a job for you
when you when you're kind of flipping
that you kind of take it a little
seriously especially when you put it in
you
gotta bread it and then you gotta put
all the different sauces on it
i can't believe you know about this this
is crazy yeah i love like the honey
barbecue sauce that was my that was my
[ __ ]
did you ever mess with the atomic wings
or anything no not really i just avoid
spice
i just i avoid it brother this is like
i'm yo this is crazy
yeah this is the i'm sorry i know this
is like the weirdest thing i've ever
done but it's pretty exciting because
it's out of my element
i'm like a vet yo when i go when i do
interviews i sit down i know who i am i
say whatever i gotta say
but this is like freaking me out in the
best way
i made my wife proud well that's a
lovely segue because i want to talk
about this great youtube video that you
posted where you woke up your wife jess
with an
orchestra playing the curb your
enthusiasm theme
and for the dudes that need to step up
the romantic gestures
can you talk about the execution and the
ideation of something like that
it all started when we were watching one
of the seasons of curb where larry wakes
up his wife cheryl
on her birthday to an orchestra and then
jeff comes in and [ __ ] it up because
he's like let's go golfing which is like
the worst thing you can do to your wife
i think on her birthday in my mind i was
like man this would be so cool i should
remember this because my wife was like
oh that's so sweet that's you know it's
like some disney [ __ ]
so i've kind of just clocked it
remembered it
and then set it all up and then there
must be something about
montgomery county and rappers and
seinfeld because
just like wale you know i see you with
the seinfeld teas and stuff and then you
had
that great line from growing pains where
you say you see these seinfeld rappers
talking a whole lot of nothing
do you feel a special affinity towards
larry david and jerry seinfeld and if so
does it inform the music at all bro i'm
so [ __ ] impressed with these
questions
thank you man sometimes you do
interviews and [ __ ] don't
really take the time to like yeah so it
means thank you
um you know i've heard a lot of people
say this especially chappelle
i think every comedian wants to be a
rapper and every rapper wants to be a
stand-up comedian in some way
i just feel like my life is one long
curb episode of
a bunch of [ __ ] that's going crazy and i
don't know how to deal with it
nice oh [ __ ]
it's almost harder that's how we
designed it very smart
anyone who knows logic knows that you
rep montgomery county proudly
and i think that you'd be the first to
admit that maryland hip-hop
is a little under the radar but i would
argue that everything about maryland is
a little bit under the radar so with
your help
i want to do a little visitor's guide to
the dmv if you're looking for me
yeah you got it what's the best regional
food specialty in maryland in your
opinion
i actually worked at a spot called joe's
crab shack so like we're known for crabs
that sounds really sus but uh but yeah
like maryland's known for crabs
like ben's chili bowl oh man in dc like
that's the spot that's where everybody
goes
mambo sauce all that like it's really
awesome so we're definitely known for
that but i would say
and marilyn is crabs name one rapper in
the region that more people should know
about
uh goldlink i i personally [ __ ] with
gold link i think he's super different
and very different i think his flow is
weird and i think that's a good thing
do you put baltimore in the maryland
because that's what people do sometimes
they go dmv baltimore
baltimore's in maryland is baltimore i
know but in a way if you're from there
you understand it's it's almost like
it's own its own world
and even the accents like you can hear
the accents are different it's really
funny i love marilyn access
did i like mo go ahead good luck that's
like all i grew up with is the [ __ ] i
love it
and uh the dmv is known for inventing
slang i don't care what anybody says
like the term thirst came from the dmv
like you thirsty or you just said that
like
yeah so they're really good at that
which is hilarious
oh [ __ ] it's getting high
all right please ask me a question i'd
be remiss
not to mention that you shared a complex
cover with neil degrasse tyson the
people's astrophysicist and a proud fan
favorite
hot ones alum and then i know he played
the voice of god
on everybody is that the feature that
you're most proud of in your rap career
yes yeah definitely um you gotta
understand like when i first
told my label and [ __ ] that i wanted to
do an album about space
you know from my sophomore house
everybody was like yeah cool
but you know to me because that's like i
just know that that's so different
and weird and even myself as a nerd i
wasn't sure how people were gonna take
it
but they actually enjoyed it and i think
there was a voice for that that's why i
love it that's why i obsess i would love
sci-fi i love all these different things
so much because i wish deep in my heart
that i could see
where we would be in 100 years 150 years
500 years from now
what's your message to certain emcees
who say that the world is flat
okay all right it's [ __ ] round
i i don't know man like just think about
it like i've literally
not to flex flown around the world and i
can ensure
you that i you know i didn't fall off
the edge of it
can i have a bottle of this i'll bring
it to my wife
that's good mind you i hate spicy [ __ ]
that's good i know that's why it's high
praise it's high praise no
all right logic so every current segment
on our show called explain that graham
we do a deep dive on our guest instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
context
so i'll show you the picture and then
you just tell me the bigger story
whoa yo playing mario kart on stage
smacked lil yachty smacked him smacked
him
he was like talking all this [ __ ] too
forever i was on tour it was my tour is
the everybody tour
and we have these humongous led walls
like screens behind me 35 shows i
brought out
somebody every single night whether it
was you know another rapper
and especially people who were a part of
the tour on the tour [ __ ]
everybody up not one loss dog 35
and oh and oh dog yes
because you played kyle like when you
think back he got [ __ ] up too
who was the closest who was the closest
to logic's level
honestly damian lamar hudson the black
spiderman himself my boy
my homie my artist damian came out one
night and it was one of the
very last nights and he hit me
with a red shell just before i crossed
the finish line
and then i was gonna go again and he hit
me with another shell because he had
three red shells that's the worst and
then he was coming up just behind me hit
me with a third shell and i
literally don't know how we did it it
was like same time we went over but i
just made it past him
yeah he was [ __ ] mad he was heated he
was thought he was the one and [ __ ] i
was like nah duck
one more for you logic okay yeah this is
fun
oh the inspiration station inspiration
station oh that's what oh that's
that's yeah oh dude that's crazy yes so
this is in my guest house in la
man i've been like busting my ass at
piano and singing and i mean really
singing because that's what i want to do
man i want to sing ballads like freddie
mercury and [ __ ] elton john
and all that and then throw some wu-tang
drums on that [ __ ] have fun
and just make music for so long i told
myself that i couldn't play the piano or
that i couldn't do
this because it wasn't hip-hop enough or
it wasn't this or whatever dumb ass
[ __ ] thing that we tell ourselves
to hold ourselves back and i was like no
i'm going to do it because i don't want
to
do the same thing over and over you know
like sometimes i'll have fans who will
be like
you know your young sinatra is the best
ever or
you know go back to the incredible truth
story or or you do more bobby tarantino
trap [ __ ] or do this
do this and there's all these [ __ ]
people telling you what to do or what
they would do if they were you but
they're not me and that's why
i'm on high ones right now um no but i
mean
that is literally the beginning of the
rest of my career
in that picture
that's like rubbery pause
pause that [ __ ] it's all good mental
health is an issue that's long been
taboo in hip-hop but that seems to be
changing a little bit
and when you think back on past eras
like with artists like dmx for example
it's kind of tragic
to think about how many serious issues
were swept under the rug or at least not
addressed for what they were
and i'm wondering from your perspective
point blank do you think more rappers
should be in therapy a hundred percent i
think more people than [ __ ] in general
which should be in therapy i've been in
therapy since 2013 you know especially
people who are in entertainment
regardless of what you do because every
day what we do is scrutinized you know
what i'm saying like literally
there's probably somebody out there like
yo he a [ __ ] he ain't finishing all the
wings you know like it's like a chill
but no matter what you do like people
are gonna always and
and that can be very very hard man but
then there's some other people that are
like
nah [ __ ] that like that that ain't
around here that's not hard that's not
this is not that and i'm like
in my mind i'm like damn that sucks hip
hop was built upon telling the truth and
being honest with yourself
it is meant to be therapeutic but i also
think as awesome and big as rap got
it's almost like this tough guy versus
whatever like i've been blessed with
this
power and i'm just going on using that
power to say like be the best you you
can be
don't throw your [ __ ] under the rug just
be you and others are doing it too and
it's awesome it's really cool that we
can unite
and really say something special
i was [ __ ] nervous when i came in
here bro
okay zombie apocalypse
oh [ __ ] yeah you know it right away
all right now i'm nervous again
so last year you launched a youtube
gaming channel and i've heard you brag
about logging 70 hours and a week and a
half to beat watcher 3.
as a musician and producer which video
game do you think has the best original
music oh
[ __ ] nobody's ever asked me anything
like that
um chrono trigger is one and then if
we're talking more
up to date pretty sure han zimmer did
like
the modern warfare 2 but even if we're
even if
uh yeah uh no i gotta go chrono trigger
and then when we had vince staples on
the show he went through yo hey yo vince
what's that you got a message for vince
i got a message for vince [ __ ]
when you're gonna come see me on
playstation you talking about his [ __ ]
you've been talking to [ __ ] for years
doc
you've been talking to [ __ ] for years
bro come see me in a playstation
because he went through a whole laundry
list of rappers that he's whooped on and
he included tyler the creator
and no well he ain't never whooped me
though because we ain't never played
he said no that he could or that he
would that's all good
it's fine he's a punk it's cool you know
we ain't never played [ __ ] so
it's you know what it's cool next time i
come back hopefully you'll have me back
yep and i'll be just talking about how i
just [ __ ] him up
are you hot like from the waist and the
wings
a little bit are you hot i'm a little
hot
[Music]
the bomb beyond indanity
[Music]
that's pretty hot bro
i'm not playing around anymore i need to
yeah
goddamn oh man there's a [ __ ] moment
right now
okay when you appeared as yourself on an
episode of rick and morty
did you write that verse or how does
that whole thing come together
yes um
oh man
[ __ ] you man yeah how you gonna do that
the last one wasn't like this it wasn't
like this bro oh
can i spit yeah you can spit take laps
all right so i get to rick and morty no
that's a year later
all right so i check i uh i tweet i
tweet justin roiland
i tweet justin roiland i'll do a
oh [ __ ] bro and i say i'll do a uh
oh man i say i'll do i'll do a voice for
any
for any uh character on your show anyone
and he's like are you serious and i'm
like yeah man i'll play a [ __ ] turd
bro
that would be amazing and then before i
knew it we met oh my lips bro
take that lap logic yo this is crazy
uh-huh
fam you this was like oh okay this is
the problem is good you know hold on and
then you just feel like you got pepper
sprayed
no and then it's this yeah and there's
hot ones which is
very good and then yeah and then you
[ __ ] me right now
yeah yeah it's a tough spot to be
definitely painted into a corner so i go
to this rick and morty opposite
oh [ __ ] dog i go to rick and morty
offices and uh
we work together and i was like here's
here's how the flow should go
sorry this is very distracting here's
how the flow should go here's how the
syllables should do this and this
i'm never going to forget this interview
bro that's good this is like crazy
wow okay [ __ ] anyway sorry so i
write it i write it and i record it and
i send it over
and that's how it happened jesus how
long did that take me
let me ask you something yeah yeah
anything you want is it
is this what's what's it like this is
next one so here let me let me put you
at ease a little bit
this one universally
every episode is the hardest one so if
you can get on top of this you can get
on top of this you can get on top of
this there it is
there it is
logic i have the tiger
i mean it's not easy though
chewy [ __ ] i'm not eating no there's
some meat right there this is
so you've done things differently your
whole career so it's not surprising that
you don't have cookie cutter heroes
you seem to be just as inspired by an
italian renaissance painter as you might
be
by a contemporary artist like j cole so
what i want to do is bounce some names
off of you and you can just tell me the
first thing that comes to mind okay
nardwar the human serviette this
interview because it's the only other
interview that i've ever done that can
compare to the [ __ ] bizarreity that
is that man i love you nard why are you
the [ __ ]
mack demarco oh man freedom
when i think about mac i think about an
artist
in many ways along with a gentleman
named by the name of toro uma
who has set me free man just make the
music you want to make have fun
and [ __ ] anything can happen and he
is one crazy [ __ ] and he's the
one of the nicest coolest welcoming
musicians i've ever met
and he ate all 10 wings let the record
show oh nice
and then i've heard you talk about that
first meeting with jay cole he bought
you a burger yeah he did buy me a burger
what are you like i'm not gonna like
this can this like physically like [ __ ]
you up
do i have to be like worried if you're
worried what am i
i've done this like a hundred times you
know what i mean yeah
okay somewhere you can get on top of one
let's go you got it
what do you remember about that burger
what kind of burger was it
i remember that it was big as [ __ ] i was
walking
going to my room and i just see this
[ __ ] tall ass dude and i was like oh
man hey what's up dude how are you he's
like oh [ __ ] it's been forever
i was like yo pull up a chair pull up a
chair i got you i've dinner with this
and i'm answering this question really
quickly and uh it was great
all right logic all right bro
all right so this is the last dab this
isn't gonna follow up right
i mean i'm not gonna make any promises
but this is the last dab we call it the
last tab give me just a little bit
cause it's tradition around here to put
a little extra on the last no not a
little extra just just like
yeah all right
go just do it all right
all right logic you've described
yourself as a rubik's cube solvent video
game-playing married puppy-loving
[ __ ] who can rap well
and over the last 10 wings we've
explored those many sides of logic
and i know that you've jumped through
this hoop before you [ __ ] have but
never with a trillion scovilles going
through you
so there you have a rubik's cube while
you're solving it i'm gonna hit you with
some jurassic park
i think that you're good for two out of
three would be chakra three out of three
what year was jurassic park released
1991 1993 1995 or 1996.
i'm gonna say 93. ding ding ding ding
ding he's one for one what did injen
scientists use to film the gaps in the
dinosaur dna
cats frogs lions or spiders frogs
ding ding ding ding ding that's two and
he's starting to fill in that rubik's
cube
one more how many humans are eaten by
dinosaurs in the film three
five seven or nine
uh
look at those mechanics i have a [ __ ]
panic attack
[Music]
the fundamentals
[Music]
damn five five five
five five three out of three on the
trivia
rubik's cube let the record show
logic what a [ __ ]
trip through the hot wing gauntlet
probably the most challenging wing ten
we've ever had but look at you
at the top of the mountain and looking
great now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend thanks this camera this camera or
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
um first of all everybody talking [ __ ]
in the comments right now [ __ ] you come
do it and then talk [ __ ]
life is good i'm excited for the future
i'm excited for music i'm excited for my
novel i'm writing for acting for
continuing to live my life and have a
[ __ ] blast and never eating
goddamn wings again uh maybe
only here uh peace of
[Applause]
[Music]
after positivity honestly it's not this
bro here yeah it's in your mouth and
here's the other thing too
is it it has a half-life so like
whatever the worse you're feeling now is
the worse you're going to feel like
in 10 minutes you'll be cool but you
know if you want to get them like a
milkshake or something that'd be nice of
you
hello hot ones fans it's shawn evans new
outro
same message if you like what you saw
throw us a bone maybe
please it is dog eat dog here on the
youtube streets
hit that subscribe button knowing that
you subscribed it is seriously the only
thing that gets me out of bed in the
morning
thank you very much hot ones fans i love
you